مرحبا بكم
مسؤول امريكيون للجزيره عن ان البيت
الابيض حاسم قراره بتزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات ابرامز وان الاعلان الرسمي سيكون
اليوم الاربعاء ونقلته وكاله اصل الشتات
بريست عن مسؤولينا امريكيين ان العمل
سيتوصلوا على صفقه دبابات الرمز لاوكرانيا
وسيتم شرائها ضمن مساعدات امنيه قادمه
وكاله الانباء الالمانيه
اوكرانيا بدبابات
وحضر المتحدث باسم الكريم سكوب من اين
تستيما كيف دبابات سيترك اثرا لا يمحى عن
العلاقات مع برلين
وقالبسكوب ان عمليات التسليم هذه لن تاتي
باي خير على العلاقات بين روسيا والمانيا
مستقبلا
ناقله التلفزيون
مصادر الدبلوماسيه تركيه ان الاجتماع
الخاص بالاله الثلاثيه بين تركيا والسويد
وفنلندا المتعلق بمسيره انضمام الاخيرهتين
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي قد تم تاجيله يذكره
ان الاجتماع الخاص بهذه المفاوضات كان من
المقرر عقده في بروكسل في شهر فبراير شباط
المقبل
وكان رئيس الوزراء السويديه وكريستيانسون
رغمت بلاده في العوده الى الحوار مع تركيا
واضاف كريسترسون انه اذا لم يكن هناك حوار
فعال فسيكون صعبا على السويد الان انضمامه
وهذا ستكون له تداعيات على امنها
من جانبه اشار وزير الخارجيه الفولادي الى
ضروره ان تدرس سهل سينكي احتمالا انضمام
الى النيته من دون السويد
جاءته هذا المتحدث باسمي وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه لديبرايز ان بلاده ترغب في
استمرار المحادثات بين السويد وفنلندا
وتركيا بشان الانضمام لحلف نيته اشاره
برايس الى ان السكر
اتخذتا جميع الاجراءاته الوفاء بتعهداتهم
ما ظن مذكره التفاهم المشتركه مع انقره
قالبين الصادر عن الديوان الملكي الاردني
ان الملك عبد الله الثاني شدد خلال لقاء
جمعه في عمان مع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بينميني تنياهو على ضروره احترام الوضع
التاريخي والقانونيه القائمه في الحرم
القدسي الشريف بينما نقلت وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه تعهد خلال لقاء من الحفاظ على
الوضع التاريخي والقانوني للاقصى
بينما دعا المتحدث باسمي وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه اسرائيل اذا الامتناع عن اي
اجراءات حاليا قد تقوض حل الدولتين بما في
ذلك المصادره الاراضي وبناء المستوطنات
وهدموا المنازل
[موسيقى]
مشاهديتها الموجز في امان الله